تسارعت حملات الاعتقالات في تونس وتكثفت
ويكاد يكون القاسم المشترك بينها انتقاد
الرئيس قيس سعيد وادارته لتونس ما بعد
الخامس والعشرين من يوليو تموز 2021 قائمه
الاعتقالات خلال الاسابيع الاخيره شملت
سياسيين بارزين وقاده النقابيين وناشطين
حقوقيين اخر هؤلاء المعتقلين عز الدين
الحزقي احد اقدم معارض النظام في تونس سجن
في زمن الرئيس الاسبق الحبيب بورقيبه
ووالد جوهر بن مبارك عضو جبهه الخراص
الملاحق من السلطات ابرز المعتقلين
السياسيين على العريض رئيس الحكومه الاسبق
ونائب رئيس حركه النهضه اعتقل في ديسمبر
الماضي بتهمه المسؤوليه عن تسفير الشباب
التونسي الى بؤر التوتر وبتهمه التامر على
الدوله اعتقل كذلك قياديان اخران من حركه
النهضه وهما عبد الحميد الجلاصي ونور
الدين البحيري وبالتهمه ذاتها اعتقل
الوزير السابق والقيادي في حزب نداء تونس
الازهر العكرمي
باسبوع اعتقل الامين العام للحزب الجمهوري
عصام الشابي ويواجه التهمه نفسها وشملت
الاعتقالات صحفيين ابرزهم نور الدين بوطار
المدير العام لاذاعه موزاييك الخاصه بسبب
الانزعاج من الخط التحريري للاذاعه حسب
محاميه وطالت الحمله رجل الاعمال كمال
الطيب الذي اعتقل بتهمه التامل على امن
الدوله وكان للمحامين قبل السياسيين نصيب
من الاعتقالات حيث اعتقل سيف الدين مخلوف
فهو كذلك عضو في البرلمان المنحل بتهمه
النيل من معنويات الجيش واعتقل مهدي
زقرويه ونضال السعيدي بتهمه الاساءه الى
موظف عمومي على خلفيه قضيه المطار اما
النقابيون المعتقلون فابرزهم انيس الكعبي
الكاتب العام للنقابه الطرق السياره
التابعه للاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل الذي
اعتقل بتهمه تعطيل مرافق الدوله وفي سلك
القضاء اعتقل النائب العام السابق وقد
التحقيق في ملف الاغتيالات السياسيه
البشير العكرمي دون توضيح التهم لمواجهه
ثم وضع في مستشفى للامراض العقليه بعدها
باسبوع